well if there were many points it was
not just a single point first of all you
have to get the idea that you can do
something about the light microscope
because people believe that this would
not be possible and it was fully
accepted in the 20th century and so I
think the first point was when I had
this kind of conviction evolving in me
that there must be a way to do something
about this diffraction whereas it is
called then I was convinced continuing
and then the second big event was when I
had the first concrete idea actually had
it when I was a postdoc in over in
Finland and I realized that you can
separate fluorescent molecules that are
closer together than this 200 nanometer
barrier by turning them on and off
playing playing with the brightness of
them and I discovered that you can use a
phenomenon which is called stimulated
emission and it's phenomenal similar
emission does nothing but keep molecules
dark shut shuts the molecules off and so
I used this phenomenon of stimulated
emission to shot molecules off turn them
off to see the daybreak one and this was
the second really important event in
this journey the third important event
was when I realized that this is doable
you can really do it in practice this
phenomenon of turning off really works
the way i dissipated and the force event
was when we got the first pictures that
demonstrated yes you can see details
much much smaller scales because you
can't keep things dark and if you have
two things that you cannot separate
normally because they hit at the same
time with big blob of light you turn
this one off to see this one then you
turn this one off to see that one and
that was as it turned out the
fundamental discovery and is that you
can see now in principle down to the
molecular scale and in practice now we
are about 20 nanometers 39 minutes
it's clear that the resolution will
increase third and further if you
perfect this say state transition that's
a technical term of going from a bright
or dark stick or between two different
states